violent animal attacks are all too real
while lots of elements of nope fall
squarely into the realm of science
fiction one plot line shares some
similarities to a real life horror story
here's how they line up spoilers for
nope ahead
jordan peele's latest film nope is out
in theaters and audiences finally know
what the film is actually about the
narrative exemplifies peel's signature
brand of storytelling examining themes
like the pursuit of fame the dark side
of exhibition and wild animals
relationship with humans it's an
adventure and a horror spectacle about
about human nature untameable beasts
play a significant role in the narrative
in more ways than one siblings o.j and
emerald haywood are struggling to
maintain their father's horse training
business after his mysterious death but
that's the least of their problems
thanks to their neighbor former child
actor and current theme park owner ricky
jupe park their property has
inadvertently become home base for a
flying extraterrestrial predator
flashbacks show that jup's fascination
with the wild creature is no coincidence
as a child he starred on a sitcom called
gordy's home which starred a live
chimpanzee alongside a group of human
actors one fateful day the primates
snapped and brutally mauled several
actors including jup's young co-star
mary jo elliott who miraculously
survived despite sustaining severe
injuries though viewers only see the
incident from jup's limited perspective
what we are shown is enough to imagine
the horror of what's happened this
section of the plot is particularly
alarming and specific so it makes sense
that gordy's violent outburst has some
clear parallels to a devastating true
story new york magazine reports that in
1995 sondra and jerome harold paid a
missouri-based breeder 50 000
in exchange for travis the chimpanzee
raising him from infancy travis
developed human qualities under their
care he got dressed every day brushed
his teeth enjoyed ice cream and wine and
even slept in bed with the couple
similar to gordy in nope travis was a
bit of a celebrity he was known for
appearing in old navy ads and local
businesses proudly displayed photographs
of him according to the stamford
advocate much like gordy travis existed
in a world where he was the center of
attention however there were warning
signs that travis might not be the
obedient pet he seemed to be the
stamford advocate also reports that the
chimpanzee pulled a woman's arm through
the opened window of a parked car in
1996 biting her hard enough to draw
blood in 2003 he jumped out of the
herald's car at an intersection evading
police and his owners for two hours at
that time no charges repressed according
to new york magazine a recurring motif
and nope is the dedication and respect
it takes to develop a connection with a
wild animal assuming obedience is a
recipe for disaster a mistake jup makes
at the cost of his life in travis's case
his perceived domestication likewise did
nothing to stop the inevitable in
february 2009 charla nash a friend of
sandra herald arrived to help care for
travis who is 14 years old and 200
pounds at the time he brutally attacked
her before being shot and killed by the
police the new york times reported
charla suffered extreme and extensive
injuries to her face and hands it's a
horrible thing but i'm not a horrible
person and he wasn't a horrible chimp
several months into her recovery charla
appeared on the oprah winfrey show to
talk about the traumatic experience for
most of the interview charla's face was
shielded by a veiled hat very similar to
the head covering we see an adult mary
jo wearing in nope when she attends
jup's alien demonstration all those
years after the gordy's home incident
although it hasn't been officially
confirmed that the gordy storyline in
nope was directly inspired by charla
nash's survival story some parallels are
clearly there of course unlike mary jo
who suffered another tragic fate nash's
condition has only improved over the
years she received a successful face
transplant in 2011 and according to abc7
has become an advocate for stricter
legislation regarding the sale of exotic
animals
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one